[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález nuestro tema
de hoy nos lleva hasta honduras en
américa central allí un juez concedió la
extradición a eeuu del ex presidente
juan orlando hernández por solicitud de
la corte del distrito sur de nueva york
el ex mandatario es acusado por
washington a por dos cargos de tráfico
de drogas y uno por uso de armas
puntualmente los fiscales de eeuu acusan
al ex mandatario de usar 15 millones de
dólares producto del narcotráfico
o del tráfico de drogas dependiendo como
se le mire para ganar la presidencia de
honduras en el 2013 la defensa de
hernández anunció que va a apelar esta
decisión de la extradición a un
procedimiento para el que tiene
solamente tres días más detalles en el
siguiente informe que fue elaborado por
la redacción de france 24
juan orlando hernández está un paso más
cerca de la extradición a eeuu un juez
de tegucigalpa autorizó la extradición
del ex mandatario quien es solicitado
por narcotráfico corrupción y tráfico de
armas de fuego por una corte de nueva
york los abogados defensores tienen tres
días para preparar una apelación está
claro de lo que resulta es una clara
violación a la soberanía una clara
violación a los derechos fundamentales
de la persona que se ordena la
extradición y en su momento a partir de
ahora estas decisiones del poder
judicial generan la respuesta
responsabilidad internacional del estado
de honduras en el marco de los derechos
humanos juan orlando hernández está
detenido desde el 15 de febrero y
continuará bajo arresto en una
instalación militar mientras la corte
suprema decide sobre el recurso de
apelación eeuu alega que hernández
formaba parte de una operación para
enviar la unión americana toneladas de
cocaína provenientes de colombia y
venezuela además se le acusa de aceptar
millones de dólares en su hornos para
impedir que narcotraficantes fueran
investigados y llevados a juicio en 2021
una corte de nueva york condenó al
hermano de hernández toni a cadena
perpetua por narcotráfico
de acuerdo con melvin duarte portavoz
del poder judicial en honduras el caso
del expresidente hernández es un proceso
de segundo grado es decir que requiere
una mínima carga probatoria para que los
requisitos que establece el tratado de
extradición firmado entre estados unidos
y honduras sean acreditados hay datos
adicionales ya luego veíamos en el
reportaje anterior juan antonio
hernández quien es conocido como tony
hernández es hermano del ex presidente
ya fue condenado a cadena perpetua en
eeuu por tráfico de drogas precisamente
otro dato importante este aval de
extradición ha generado una gran
controversia en este país
centroaméricano miles de partidarios del
ex mandatario se han manifestado para
darle su apoyo mientras que otros
sectores sociales y políticos respaldan
precisamente esa solicitud de washington
y la decisión que ha dado la justicia
hondureña mientras que otros han
calificado este caso como una venganza
política que hay detrás del caso de juan
orlando hernández será o no será
extraditado a eeuu lo vamos a analizar
en unos minutos aquí en el debate de
france 24 y para analizar este tema
saludamos
ella es experta en derecho
constitucional también es docente
universitaria ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de tegucigalpa también allí en la
capital hondureña está con nosotros
edgardo rodríguez él es politólogo y
también consultor nacional e
internacional en temas políticos y
sociales ustedes también son parte de
este debate a través de las redes
sociales pueden dejar todos los
comentarios y preguntas que deseen lo
pueden hacer a través de facebook de
instagram y de twitter estamos como
france24
sant y luego que es mi cuenta personal y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 para que dejen allí los
comentarios comienzo entonces con ana
ana pineda bienvenida a ella se
encuentra como lo decía en la ciudad de
tegucigalpa y comienzo en preguntándole
tal vez la pregunta clave todo este
debate anna juan orlando hernández
cuáles son sus chances de quedarse en
honduras o será extraditado a eeuu con
esto abre el debate
un buen día un gusto saludarle
bueno yo creo que no hay forma de pensar
en este momento que el exgobernante juan
orlando hernández
pueda quedarse en honduras como bien se
decía en la introducción al debate en
nuestro país y aún pues natural tuvo la
oportunidad de conocer los medios de
prueba y la evacuación de los medios de
pueblo que correspondía presentarlos
tanto por parte del estado requirente en
este caso eeuu y por otro lado en la
defensa del exgobernante en este caso en
particular aquí no se va a sustentar una
prueba en el sentido amplio de la
palabra lo que se hace es la
acreditación de los mínimos elementos de
prueba en este caso en particular de lo
que el juez valoró
exista una causa probable de
participación en los cargos que le está
imputando
eeuu y en ese sentido el juez natural
llegó a la resolución de que debe
otorgársele el la extradición
corresponde que la defensa dentro de los
tres días siguientes a la notificación
interponga un recurso de apelación
ese recurso de apelación tendrá que
ser admitido como corresponda en el
procedimiento establecido en el tratado
e inmediatamente a su admisión se le
contestará a los labios del estado
requirente y una vez contestado se
remite al pleno de la corte suprema y en
la que finalmente lo va a resolver y sin
duda alguna tiene tres formas de
resolverlo otra o lograr la extradición
de negarla o reformarla y en este caso
todo indica que va a ser otorgada la
extradición y consecuentemente entregado
saludo a edgardo rodríguez
hace algunos minutos él también se
encuentra en tegucigalpa la capital
hondureña y la misma pregunta edgardo
bienvenido al programa como punto de
partida es si es inminente esta
extradición del ex presidente juan
orlando hernández a cortes de eeuu
qué tal buenas
saludos desde tegucigalpa
y coincido con la fuga pineda si
seguimos la lógica de las 33
extradiciones anteriores o 32
y tomando en cuenta lo que han dicho los
abogados penalistas que esto es un puro
trámite lo que se hace lo que hacen en
la corte suprema de justicia no lo digo
yo lo dicen
destacados penalistas hondureños seguro
trámite
y es inminente y considero de acuerdo
que es inminente la extradición del ex
presidente vamos hablando hernández
hacia los eeuu por la forma en que se
consiguió esto que se llama el auto
acortado no es una ley de extradición y
la forma en cómo se concibió es bastante
digamos expedita basta con que eeuu y
solicite y presente pues algunos
argumentos para que sea concedida la
extradición de acuerdo repito a lo que
varios juristas nacionales han destacado
sobre el procedimiento siguiendo esa
lógica sigue negando todo indica que el
asad es calentado edgardo continuo con
usted para hacer la ronda la inversa ya
voy con usted a na para seguir hablando
de algunos puntos legales esto como
afecta a edgardo en materia política a
honduras un país que se repone todavía
cerrando algunas heridas del golpe de
estado de principios de la década del
2000 o un poco posteriores del 2009
y de los hechos que se han venido
sucediendo en los últimos años en este
país centroamericano este golpe que un
ex presidente que recientemente terminó
su mandato vaya a terminar ante las
cortes de eeuu respondiendo por
narcotráfico como golpeas toda la
política del país
muy duro sin duda alguna muy duro
especialmente al partido del
expresidente hernández muy duro el golpe
inmoral el golpe político también la
imagen de honduras en el exterior
sigue siendo deteriorada por este tipo
de escándalos ilegales pero además que
va a haber repercusiones no solamente
para el partido político del ex
presidente sino que también en la lucha
contra narcotráfico y varios
distinguidos
políticos de la oposición de honduras se
han preguntado quién va a querer seguir
luchando contra el narcotráfico en
honduras esa es la gran pregunta y una
de las consecuencias de las varias
consecuencias que esto va a tener es la
lucha contra narcotráfico me preguntó
que de presidente o presidenta va a
querer luchar contra el narcotráfico
está viendo el poder que tienen y
sabiendo que pueden ocurrir situaciones
como las que han ocurrido y esa es una
cosa que lo acaban de decir varios
políticos de la oposición es una
situación también que genera efectos
colaterales
políticos jurídicos de
gobernabilidad para honduras de todo
dentro de un conjunto lamentable de
circunstancias
retomo la comunicación con usted también
allí en la ciudad de tegucigalpa la
capital hondureña veíamos en el
reportaje previo a la presentación de
ustedes como invitados del programa
algunas denuncias de violaciones de la
soberanía y también de violaciones de
los derechos humanos dentro del marco
legal hondureño y dentro de este tratado
de extradición firmado entre los dos
países estas afirmaciones que se pueden
decir son ciertas o son simplemente
comentarios al aire en medios de
comunicación para para generar confusión
entre los hondureños
son comentarios al aire como bien usted
lo define parte de una estrategia de la
defensa al aseverar esto todos los
estados una vez que deciden suscribir un
tratado internacional de cualquier
naturaleza
comprometen su soberanía en consecuencia
son llamados a cumplir los preceptos de
esos tratados no se debe de perder de
vista en este caso en particular que la
figura de la extradición es una figura
propia del derecho internacional que los
estados deciden proteger determinados
bienes jurídicos frente a los ilícitos
transnacionales graves y en este caso en
particular eeuu ha suscrito dos tratados
de extradición con honduras uno en 1909
y otro en
1927 y además de ello la constitución de
nuestro país se reformó para el
habilitar la extradición en los casos de
criminalidad organizada terrorismo y
narcotráfico así que aparte de estos
tratados y de la norma constitucional
también en honduras es signataria de
otros tratados internacionales como la
convención de las naciones unidas contra
la criminalidad
luego la delincuencia organizada
transnacional que también le impone la
responsabilidad de prevenir y de
perseguir conductas como la del
narcotráfico por lo tanto no tiene
fundamentación alguna el que se haya
violentado nuestra soberanía o los
derechos de la persona que va a ser
extraditada anahí que hay en cuanto a la
apelación en la defensa de juan orlando
hernández tiene tres días para hacer
presentación de esta apelación ante las
autoridades hondureñas pero hay 20
medios a favor que fueron presentados
por el gobierno de eeuu a través de la
embajada en tegucigalpa en donde
explican todo el caso y donde ponen en
evidencia
las pruebas que tienen las cortes en
eeuu para haber hecho esta acusación del
ex mandatario esta apelación desde el
punto de vista legal también y desde su
punto de vista usted cómo lo ve hay
chances hay oportunidades que de pronto
pueda tal vez retrasar o darle un poco
de tiempo a la defensa de hernández para
preparar mejor el caso o simplemente
pues se va a hacer este trámite como por
cumplir con un trámite más pero no va a
sortear ningún efecto es un trámite más
será cuestión de días para que el
exgobernante sea entregado a los eeuu lo
que harán la defensa y esto lo opino
como jueza en materia de lo criminal que
fui va a interponer el recurso
posiblemente en las últimas horas del
vencimiento del plazo es decir dentro de
los tres días siguientes con el
propósito de prolongar una vía unos días
más la estadía del exgobernante luego el
pleno de la corte tendrá igualmente el
mismo tiempo para resolver de manera
definitiva ese recurso de apelación en
el que estoy absolutamente convencida
que terminar otorgando lo confirmando el
otorgamiento para la extradición del
gobernante en otras palabras que estadía
del gobernante en el país es cuestión de
días edgardo llama la atención esta
relación que ha tenido honduras con el
narcotráfico como está permeado
diferentes sectores de la clase política
y también de la sociedad hondureña
quiero que vale la pena que nos ponga en
contexto la relación que tiene este país
con esta industria con los cárteles
mexicanos y colombianos y también
centroamericanos y qué importancia tiene
honduras en esta en este eslabón de qué
eslabón representa en la cadena del
narcotráfico de una industria que viene
desde el sur hacia el norte tratando de
llegar a estados unidos que es el
mercado más grande y más apetecidos por
los narcotraficantes
y evidentemente es honduras y
centroamérica porque
los reflectores están puestos en
honduras pero el narcotráfico se mueve
por toda la región centroamericana
estamos en el paso entre las drogas que
sale de venezuela de colombia y hacia
estados unidos pasando por méxico a una
parte y otra parte paul y caribe y el
pacífico
y el narcotráfico
las organizaciones del narcotráfico en
méxico y en venezuela y por eso también
en general encontraron en centroamérica
y en honduras una fragilidad
institucional importante en los
operadores de justicia de los órganos de
seguridad en los partidos políticos en
el sistema empresarial y que le permitió
permear este este ilícito como es el
narcotráfico
y fueron debilitadas las instituciones
fueron penetradas cooptadas por con
dinero y por estas organizaciones y eso
evidentemente pues hizo caer al país a
la región centroamericana y está en este
esquema delictivo tan poderoso que les
recuerdo es la segunda actividad que
mueve más dinero en el mundo entero
después de la producción y venta de
petróleo el narcotráfico es la segunda
actividad más lucrativa del planeta
and i' que hay de la justicia hondureña
que están permeadas está la justicia de
este país centroamericano con los grupos
delincuenciales ligados al narcotráfico
allí en honduras y que tanto se puede
confiar en la independencia de la
industria de la industria perdón de la
justicia hondureña en cuanto a este tipo
de casos puntuales que afectan a un
exmandatario ligado a la industria del
narcotráfico
con muchas penas como hondureña que soy
tengo que reconocer que estos 14 años
últimos en nuestro país hubo una
cooptación de la institucionalidad en
general pero principalmente de las
instituciones que les corresponde
investigar perseguir y sancionar el
delito de narcotráfico y criminalidad
organizada en términos generales sí ha
sido altamente permeada prueba de ello
es que el
gobernante de nuestro país quien se
desempeñó como presidente del congreso
nacional y posteriormente presidente de
la república por dos periodos
consecutivos ha estado involucrado y en
la solicitud de
pedido de extradición que hace los eeuu
también revela que él hizo partícipe a
las fuerzas policiales a las fuerzas
militares para que protegieron a los
narcotraficantes y pudieran cometer
delitos a grave de manera impune que con
esto lo único que nos demuestra que las
instituciones del sistema de justicia no
tuvieron capacidad para investigar todos
estos actos graves en nuestro país y que
tuvo que ser la justicia de eeuu la que
finalmente
permitiera deducir la responsabilidad
mediante la extradición de estos
compartidos a edgardo quiero que los dos
respondan a esta misma pregunta que les
voy a hacer y es
tomando como punto de partida en algunas
palabras del ex presidente juan orlando
hernández quien ha declarado que estas
acusaciones en su contra son parte de
criminales confesos en eeuu que están
llevando a cabo una venganza por la
lucha que él
y emprendió contra el narcotráfico
durante este gobierno de juan orlando
hernández cómo fue esa supuesta lucha
contra el narcotráfico comienzo entonces
con edgardo para ir armando este
rompecabezas en cuanto a estas
acusaciones
bueno primero quiero hacer una precisión
en narcotráfico nos en todos sus bases
en honduras en los últimos 14 años desde
el inicio de la década del año 2000
especialmente también de partir del año
2006 cuando el ex gobernante manuel
zelaya presidía honduras y de ahí empezó
una cantidad enorme de entrada de
narcoavionetas y otro tipo de vehículos
con cocaína honduras incluso hay
señalamientos muy serios que se han
hecho a funcionarios militares y
policiales la policía de aquel entonces
estuvo totalmente
penetrada por el narcotráfico desde los
últimos 14 años
respecto a la lucha contra el
narcotráfico esta es una cosa también
que hace este asunto sumamente complejo
del asunto de la expresión interna antes
no se queda en la simple acusación y
extradición de él porque estamos frente
a algún presidente
desarrolló una serie de instituciones de
ley es la misma el mismo auto acordado
desde la corte suprema se dio en el
marco de la presidencia del congreso del
presidente van guardando y también la
creación de una serie de unidades de
combate al narcotráfico se dieron una
serie de leyes y de acciones
contundentes con ternasco tráficos por
eso este es un problema que tiene
aristas muy profundas muchas de ellas no
las conocemos y no sé si con el paso de
los años las iremos a conocer a
profundidad pero lo cierto es que no se
puede negar que hubo una serie de
acciones contundentes de lucha contra el
narcotráfico en nuestro país sin embargo
esto es parte de esta complejidad de
este de este delito y de esta trama tan
profunda y tan amplia como es la
acusación y la muy probable extradición
del ex presidente hacia eeuu hay
afección hay muy profundo y no hay
todavía las
evidencias y todavía los elementos
suficientes para desentrañar eso que
estoy diciendo hubo una persona que
luchó frontalmente contra el
narcotráfico termina siendo parte de la
vorágine en esta lucha claro gana su
opinión sobre este tema que tanto se
luchó contra el narcotráfico
puntualmente durante el gobierno de juan
orlando hernández
bueno una contra aclaración lo que yo
dije es que la cooptación de las
instituciones en general y de las
instituciones del sistema de justicia se
había reforzado justamente en estos años
en que el exgobernante se desempeñó en
la titularidad del congreso y en la
presidencia de la república por dos años
consecutivos en juan orlando hernández
desde el congreso nacional como del
ejecutivo mandaba por un lado mensajes
de que quería combatir el narcotráfico y
la criminalidad organizada no obstante
la práctica nos demuestra que ninguno de
esos esfuerzos fueron efectivos si eso
fuera así el mismo no estaría siendo
objeto de un enjuiciamiento en eeuu por
otro lado tampoco se estarían
mencionando en la corte del distrito sur
de los eeuu en este momento a políticos
influyentes de nuestro país cercanos
colaboradores del ex gobernante como a
policía y a militares estamos viendo
cómo está pendiente también de
extradición en estos días quien fuera el
director nacional de la policía nacional
consecuentemente los esfuerzos que se
decían hacer no fueron efectivos y eso
es lo que está demostrando los 97
solicitudes de extradición que los eeuu
ha formalizado a honduras de las cuales
sólo 34 estarían como con posibilidades
de cumplirse no se puede hablar tampoco
que es una venganza porque lo que se
busca cuando se investiga una
conspiración es que una persona en
particular que ha tenido un grado de
participación en el delito con cierta o
se pone de acuerdo con otros para llevar
a cabo esa acción delictiva porque ha
puesto que aquí en eeuu ha buscado como
personas para que den cuenta de estos
extremos es a esas personas que se
suponen habían concertado con el
gobernante por lo tanto no cabe el
calificativo de venganza sino únicamente
de una investigación efectiva en eeuu
anna usted me lleva justamente a la
siguiente pregunta que tenía preparada
para ustedes y es si esto es simplemente
la punta del iceberg de una gran
investigación el ex presidente es el
primero en ser procesado ex mandatario y
perteneciente al gobierno anterior de
honduras y que poco a poco se vayan
dando a conocer más nombres de otros
funcionarios o personas al exmandatario
que podrían estar involucradas usted
cree que esto podría ser así que esto es
solamente el inicio de algo más grande
si efectivamente ya se cuentan con
sentencias de otros compatriotas donde
con claridad se pueden hacer las
menciones que hacen los fiscales que han
tenido el conocimiento de esos casos en
donde ya se habla de otros conspiradores
los cuales en algún momento con nombre
han trascendido el congreso nacional de
nuestro país ha nombrado una comisión de
investigación para que dé cuenta de cuál
ha sido el número de solicitudes y por
qué las mismas no han sido debidamente
investigadas detenidas y extraditadas
estas personas y eso evidentemente lo
que nos demuestra es que hay ahí nombres
de personas que incluso tienen el
calificativo de cercanos colaboradores y
miembros activos de la influyente clase
política que ha gobernado en los últimos
años en nuestro país
edgardo y en su en su opinión este tipo
de casos esta solicitud de extradición
en este caso abierto así el exmandatario
hondureño y también estos nombres que
mencionan a de otros funcionarios como
el de la policía por ejemplo que están
ligados a estas acusaciones como te ha
parado al estado hondureño como
institución al estado de derecho
hondureño y también a la clase política
de este país deja sin duda alguna un mal
precedente y un sinsabor para los
ciudadanos que están viendo como sus
funcionarios sus instituciones y su
estado está siendo afectado por el
narcotráfico y pues están siendo
solicitado por eeuu
evidentemente evidentemente que deja muy
mal parado a las instituciones al
gobierno y ojalá que también se
investigue porque hasta este momento hay
un sesgo hay un sesgo muy fuerte de las
últimas tres administraciones de
gobierno y por qué digo tercero por
parte de los fiscales norteamericanos
que por cierto el fiscal del distrito
sur de nueva york el señor en mi libro
fue combinado a renunciar en el año 2019
2020 por por manipulación de pruebas que
a mí me da un poco de que pensar porque
habiendo tantos casos sonados entre el
año 2006 y 2009 la fiscalía del distrito
sur de nueva york y no digamos toman
líneas de acción respecto a ese pedido
sino que los últimos tres gobiernos que
no los estoy defendiendo ni diciendo que
no ha habido actividades ilícitas sino
que ha pasado entre el periodo 2006 y
2009 que hay una especie de silencio
cómplice por parte de la fiscalía del
distrito sur de los eeuu
el gobierno las instituciones vamos a
ver si el actual gobierno que dirige la
presidenta sumara castro toma nota de
todo lo que está sucediendo para retomar
el fortalecimiento del estado de derecho
de las instituciones en nuestro país ese
es el reto que tiene el actual gobierno
e interesar llamémoslo así las
instituciones
edgardo ml usted la mente justo con la
pregunta que le iba a hacer a
continuación y es sobre el gobierno
actual del gobierno precedido por la
presidenta castro que han dicho las
autoridades actuales de honduras
referente a este caso que han dicho
desde el palacio de gobierno o que ha
dicho la presidenta en torno a este tema
ya usted no menciona el gran reto que
tienen por delante volver a ganar la
credibilidad de la institucionalidad
hondureña ante los ciudadanos pero que
dicen sobre este caso
bueno oficialmente no se ha dicho
absolutamente nada no hay ninguna
declaración oficial de la presidenta o
de su marido quien es el principal
operador del gobierno después de que
ella ninguno de sus altos funcionarios
no hay ninguna declaración pero
obviamente la pelota ahora está en la
cancha de la presidenta y respecto a
todo lo que estamos hablando del
respecto a todo lo que ya se sabe la
penetración del narcotráfico en la
sociedad hondureña en las instituciones
más importantes del gobierno que van a
hacer cómo va a actuar respecto a todo
esto es la pregunta que ahora entonces
nos hacemos los hondureños ok ya se
están procesando a estas personas les
presidente vendrán otras solicitudes de
extradición pero la cosa no termina ahí
la cocaína sigue circulando en honduras
la muerte violenta van en ascenso en
honduras y la violencia sigue repuntando
en el país así que el gobierno de la
presidenta acción para castró tiene un
reto enorme para demostrar
en realidad llegué a hacer las cosas
diferentes como lo habían dicho durante
estos últimos 12 años del gobierno
nacionalista ahora tienen el turno
entonces de
reconstituir el estado de derecho de
ciudad y vamos a eliminar todas estas
amenazas acabar con el narcotráfico con
las maras y pandillas que han buscado y
a su lado la vida de los ciudadanos
hondureños en la tarea enorme de la
presidenta y humana castro van a retomar
la comunicación con ustedes y en
tegucigalpa la capital hondureña para
preguntarle y ampliar este tema del
gobierno actual que pueden hacer para
avanzar en esta lucha contra el
narcotráfico y que en posiciones toman
los gobiernos en este tipo de
acusaciones cuando hay una solicitud de
extradición por un país por un segundo
país por autoridades de otro país esto
en términos legales cómo se maneja desde
el punto de vista del gobierno
bueno una vez que un estado suscribe un
tratado internacional ese tratado pasa a
formar parte de su derecho interno y de
acuerdo al principio conocido como pacta
sunt servanda o de buena fe los estados
tienen que adoptar medidas
administrativas legislativas
judiciales y de cualquier otra
naturaleza que sean pertinentes para
poder cumplir con los términos del
tratado consecuentemente siendo la
extradición una figura del derecho
internacional el nuevo gobierno también
debe continuar
aplicando dichos tratados
internacionales y luego creo que un reto
inmediato que tiene el actual gobierno
por supuesto es revisar la
institucionalidad nacional todas
aquellas normativas que involución aaron
la prevención en la lucha contra el
narcotráfico y la criminalidad
organizada en general remover esos
obstáculos y algo muy importante que si
lo ha manifestado públicamente la actual
presidenta de la república es que ha
solicitado a la secretaria general de
las naciones unidas la instalación de
una comisión internacional contra la
corrupción y la impunidad en honduras
que permita por un lado el
fortalecimiento de las instituciones
nacionales para que no sea más eeuu
investigando a quienes cometen delitos
graves en nuestro país sino que sean las
instituciones que tienen el mandato y el
presupuesto para hacerlo así que creemos
que la instalación de la comisión va a
marcar una gran diferencia de cara al
fortalecimiento del estado de derecho y
la lucha contra la criminalidad
organizada
para edgardo estamos en la recta final
del programa tengo que cerrar con las
conclusiones de lo que va a venir para
este país centroamericano a partir de lo
que está sucediendo en el caso del ex
presidente juan orlando hernández esta
posible apelación que de ser presentada
será definida por la corte suprema de
honduras el definirán si aceptan o no
esta apelación y si lo envían ya
definitivamente a eeuu o no y que puede
y causar esto en el futuro político
inmediato de este país centroamericano
edgardo comienzo con usted para la
conclusión
fíjense que no soy muy optimista
respecto a la lucha contra la corrupción
y la depuración de las instituciones
porque de entrada la actual presidenta
en el partido y la coalición del partido
con la que gobierna aprobó una ley que
le da impunidad total a personas que
estaban vinculadas a robo del erario
público delitos comunes y no delitos
políticos se encubrió con una supuesta
ley de amnistía política y se ha dejado
libre a una serie de personajes
vinculados a actos de corrupción nos da
un mensaje desalentador respecto a lo
que vamos a ver lo que dice la abogada y
se ha perdido naciones unidas en una
condición de lucha contra la corrupción
pero es una lucha que va en una comisión
que va a perseguir a la oposición ahora
y ha perdonado a los a todos las
personas que están vinculadas al partido
de gobierno de esa ley fue aprobada en
los primeros días de la actual
administración así que el futuro
inmediato se presenta
con estos pactos de impunidad que se
hace
a favor del gobierno
con impunidad en contra de la alianza de
personas vinculadas al gobierno anterior
si el perdón que los cortes gastos que
me quedan pocos segundos y necesito la
conclusión de anna rápidamente por favor
ana muy puntual para el cierre del
programa
bueno decir que con cada extradición que
se produce en nuestro país se
comprometen la independencia y la
imparcialidad de la investigación del
delito
confiaríamos que a partir de lo que
ahora vemos sirva como una lección
aprendida y podamos mejorar en esta
materia dado que el pueblo hondureño es
digno de una mejor suerte y sin duda
creemos que se están creando las
condiciones para avanzar en el
fortalecimiento de nuestro estado de
derecho
edgardo ya en la ciudad de tegucigalpa
muchas gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 en toda américa
latina ustedes muchas gracias por la
sintonía siga con france 24
[Música]